the desperate search by many americans
for guidance and resources in the fight
against this omicron variant
hospitalizations from covett are up 33
percent in the last week alone and the
deaths are up 40 percent today president
biden will announce that additional
medical teams will be deployed to
specific hospitals in need but a lack of
adequate testing is also making obicon
very difficult to fight chris van cleave
is at a testing center in washington d.c
with more on this story chris good
morning to you
good morning gail finding at home test
kits like this can still resemble a bit
of a scavenger hunt in many places even
as states are ramping up testing
capacity nearly three million tests are
being given a day more than a quarter
more than one in four are coming back
positive
hospitals across the country are
struggling to deal with the omicron
surge the sudden and steep rise in cases
due to omicron is resulting in
unprecedented daily case counts
sickness
absenteeism and strains on our health
care system president biden is now
deploying military medical teams to
support health care workers in
overwhelmed emergency rooms in six
states new york new jersey ohio rhode
island michigan and new mexico
virtually everybody is going to wind up
getting exposed and likely get infected
the administration is also rolling out a
new effort to improve testing at schools
sending 5 million rapid tests and
another 5 million lab based tests each
month the president is clear the
nation's schools can and should be open
jessica jodinez was getting tested at
one of six recently added testing sites
in san antonio
she worries about bringing the virus
home to her one-year-old daughter it's
very concerning because a lot of people
just go with us and work at school
and i can't protect her from it
san antonio's university hospital er is
already seeing dozens more patients a
day than it was a month ago many people
are showing up just looking for tests
stay home talk to your primary care
physician see where you could go get
tested
within your community
and keep the emergency room available
for true emergencies don't come here for
a test absolutely not
a senior administration official tells
cbs news they expect around 575 million
at home test kits to be available in the
u.s this month starting saturday private
insurers will have to reimburse people
for home kits nate
chris thank you so much